All right, first up,
this little list of links in the header.
If I inspect one of those links,
I could see it's in a div
with the class of blog nav.
So that could just as
easily be a nav element.
Next, this big green section,
it's under the hero section.
And I see something called row.
But I think that's just
a layout helper div so
I'm going to drill a little deeper.
The next element we see
has a class of col-sm-8
which seems like a grid system class,
but also blog-main.
So that's probably a good candidate for
our main element.
This sidebar here,
this one's a little tricky.
But if we look through our
list of semantic elements,
we see there is one called aside.
The spec says of aside
that it can be used for
groups of nav elements and
for other content
that is considered separate from
the main content of the page.
So we could definitely
use an aside here.
Finally, right inside the main element
we have something called blog-post.
Now there's no post element, but
there is certainly an article element
and that would work really well here.